hi everyone welcome back in
we're gonna start the next session it's
my pleasure to introduce Ali mordazavi
who's here from UCI
all right
thank you for for the introduction so um
I'm going to uh tell you about the
developing story which is our efforts to
analyze the long read transcriptum data
from encode 4.
and I realized that there's a lot of you
in this room who are part of encode and
so it shouldn't need an introduction but
at the same time I thought it's
worthwhile now that the project is
officially over to sort of see what's
happened over the last 19 years and
it'll probably be 20 years by the time
the last set of papers come out
and to see
um
how this one project has actually driven
quite a bit of of the
genomics infrastructure that we use for
day-to-day functional genomics
so the original pilot came out of
actually the end of the human genome
sequencing project
where we had the sequence of a genome
and very little idea what it was all
about right and so the the idea was that
we had a puzzle uh we had the three
billion pieces of it and the question
was what were the significant portions
of it
and at the time uh we did not have the
platforms to be able to actually do
whole genome analysis this was the time
when you could do a whole genome maybe
in a yeast maybe in a fly maybe but
realistically when you were talking
about doing analysis in human uh the
whole pilot phase was based on trying to
do the analysis of one percent of the
human genome right with the thought that
we could pick a set of different regions
learn something about them using a
variety of techniques and hopefully
figure out
some way to then take this project to
the next phase which was always going to
be the scallop to the whole genome
and uh the one set of techniques that
really did enable and code to scale
genome-wide was the development of
Mexican urgent sequencing and of
techniques such as chip stick and
rna-seq which were developed really as
part of rampa Franklin tube so um I
remember those days pretty well
uh
a lot of the the different groups that
were proposing projects were in code two
we're still talking about doing macro
Ras one group proposed to do chipsy and
rna-seq by the time they revised all
their proposals when it came time to
funding they had all switched to doing
Chopstick analysis this thing caught up
really quickly and ever since then we've
been uh doing this now in code two
famously was cell line based
and I think in the mind of a lot of the
genomics community it's still primarily
about cell lines
right hundreds of chipsy data sets and
k560 and have G2 for example
but encode 3 uh decided to take this
encyclopedia
term that was part of the the clever
naming that uh Elise Feingold had come
up with and tried to actually criticize
it to make it a concrete actual
Encyclopedia of regulatory element and
so people such as shipping who's in the
audience
took the lead to actually build an
encyclopedia of candid regulatory
elements
now we also at that point started adding
data from human tissues there was also a
really beautiful embryonic Mouse
uh time course that was that came here
and
those papers describing the effort that
finished in 2017 just were published in
2020. and so that's probably what most
of you have heard about
now uh
the the project did go through a fourth
and Final Phase
um
and I want to talk a little bit about
one part of it which is the part I'm
involved with which is adding long reads
to the rna-seq part of encode but uh I
would be remiss if I didn't mention that
in addition to the main input efforts
the whole set of other projects came out
of it uh for example gen code started
actually as a part of encoda then became
its own project
I as well as for example the LR gas
Consortium which Anna here is leading uh
which was involved in comparing
different uh long read platforms
so
um to give you a sense of the kind of
size that we're talking about
there is over 2500 RNA sequencing
related data sets that have been
released by encode so far
um and as I mentioned I'm only going to
focus on one section of it which is the
human long retail sets and I'll tell you
more about it but why long reads I'm
sure Hagen already convinced you that
long reads is the only way to go
yesterday but but just to to repeat the
obvious
uh if we're actually interested in
understanding how it is that the
proteome is Diversified if you if you
guys recall before with the sequence of
even genome we thought there were 100
000 genes and we were shocked to find
out that there were only a 20 000
freaking coding genes right the the
result was that actually there were many
isoforms that you could detect using
those 2D um
protein gels that were coming from
different isoforms of the same gene
however it's really difficult to
actually study that using Illumina reads
alone whereas if you had truly long
reads that went from the beginning to
the end of your isoforms then you've
taken a really difficult problem of
trying to reconstruct things and convert
it into a trivial problem which is just
simply counting the full length streets
now the project
started in 2017 and at that point we
decided to go with track biosequencing
and I think that was actually a good
choice
um I'll admit that I now have a external
for grid ion in my lab but I don't think
that I could be telling you what I'm
going to tell you about our reads
um using uh you know not up for
sequencing from States three four years
ago
and let me try to show you what I mean
by that so it's worth thinking that not
all long reads are equivalent
uh this is actually the one figure I'll
show from the LR gas pre-pint
uh which is uh showing in the Swarm plot
the
um the length of the different reads
from the different uh data sets that
were generated
and you can see that here we're plotting
the length in KB of these reads on to
the Chino
and you can see for example that the
cdna pack bio is substantially different
than for example the cdna ont
right the cdna or NT reads are longer
reached than you what you get with
Illumina let's say but obviously they're
not as long as what you can get for the
same material using uh papaya now
there's another possibility which is
that it's not just
about the platform
but it's also about the way you prepare
the cdna
so in fact uh I would say that you can
actually move this so that your uh your
mean length is not 800 base pairs but
closer to a couple KB by just changing
the underlying cdna preparation steps
purpose is this is what the encode pack
bio data looks like and and the reason
why this is an interesting set of links
is because the average mRNA and the
human genome somewhere around 2kb Long
which means that for many many of the
genes we're going to be able to actually
sequence from the beginning to the end
of the MRNA
okay
okay uh now
there are
160 some data sets I believe
that are now publicly available on the
include portal
uh about a hundred of them are human 99
I think and the rest are Mouse uh they
spend a whole set of tissues and cell
lines
and all together they account for at
least a billion CCP CCS pack bio reads
so these are the error corrected packed
by reads
and we estimate that about 200 million
of them are actually really full lengths
and that makes it one of the largest and
most comprehensive collections of human
and mouse Marine RNC data sets
okay so that's for like the um the raw
data part of it now the question is what
do you do with this data
and with long reads
we've had this ongoing issue of trying
to figure out whether two transcripts
are the same or not that's not an issue
when you see a novel Exon or something
but it's an issue when you see that the
five parameter three prime ends are
different
and we have a secondary issue which is
that we see a lot of reads that look
like they're degraded reads but we know
that there are also these shorter
isoforms and the question is can we
really tell them apart or not
and I've been showing this slide for
many many years and really it's only in
the last couple of months I've convinced
myself that we can actually take care of
this problem now
okay so uh when talking about long reads
we actually use
um these isoform novelty categories
which Anna developed in her s quantity
paper
uh where we actually describe whether
the isoforms that we see are matching at
the level of these intron chains known
isoforms or not
uh when we have
transcripts that match part of isoforms
we tend to call them incomplete splice
matches
and the one thing that we've changed
recently is that now we can look at all
of our reads and we think we can rescue
about 20 of these and say that they are
likely to be true transcripts but that
means that you know there's 80 of these
that are really
just uh parts of full transcripts
which you could try to assemble into
full transcripts but in our case we will
just let them go by the side
all right so uh there are other novelty
categories that you might see for
example you might see new combination of
existing exons we'll call that novel in
catalog and then there's these these
transcripts that have new exons and so
those are called novel not in catalog
the pipeline that we're using was
developed in my lab over the years
um if I started it today maybe I would
not have just so many different steps
here maybe I'd skip a couple but right
this moment it starts by taking the the
CCS reads mapping them with minimap
uh correct thing done with transcript
clean and throwing out all of the novel
non-canonical spice Junctions uh
and then we actually then look at which
transcripts match which isoforms using
Talon we correct the ends with lapa and
I'll tell you about that in a minute and
the latest and greatest is that we have
now an additional package
uh called Cerberus that we use in order
to try to categorize uh the transcript
isoform novelty
um
and then we have packages for doing
Downstream analysis such as Swan which
we already published
very briefly
the way lapa works is that we're just
simply essentially going to do pick
calling on ends of these reads
the key assumption is that RNA
degradations can be less reproducible
than
um true ends there are still some
specific artifacts such as internal
priming that we have to do is but but
that's that's easily billable and then
the the very first version of lapid that
we wrote was trying to fix three prime
ends and it's really only over the last
few months as part of the uh encodile
networking group work that we think that
we now have the TSS ends fixed up
okay so so lapa is actually going to
generate a gtf file that's got all of
the transcripts that um
that we have seen across those 160 long
read data sets
and you know that's a huge mess
though the one thing that we decided to
do was to try to see whether we could
characterize our isoforms
based on how different they were
both in their intron chain and their
ends and so that's actually what
Cerberus is doing
so Cerberus
deals with the fact that for every
isoform
we can say what end it has either five
Prime end that just says we can
categorize which intronic chain it has
and also which three prime end it has
and so essentially it's uh rather than
having I say for example I don't know
pack six dash 106 for you know the iso
for The Hundreds the six ISO form of
pack six we can instead say okay well
this ISO form has the first and
uh it has maybe the second intran chain
and it has the second uh Tes
this allows us to Now quickly start
comparing isoforms by saying okay do
they share the same time and do they
share the same intron chain and so on
uh as part of of developing this and
talking to the folks at gen code I
should say that I'm on The Advisory
Board of gen code uh we decided to
always make sure that the 111 triplet so
the the the transcript ISO form that
gets the 111 designation is going to
match the ncbi
Ensemble main select which is supposed
to be the representative transcript if
you live in that world where you don't
want to think of alternate splicing
uh gen code and ncbi want to give you
one transcript to represent SD
transcript right and that's the main
select so that's one one and so whenever
in our triplets you see that you don't
see the number one by definition it
cannot be the main ISO form that uh gen
code and ncbi Report
all right so why did we break this up
into three pieces
uh the goal was to try to characterize
the different ways that is isoform
diversity could arise specifically
the selection of the TSS is really about
promoter choice and transcriptional
regulation more so than anything else
whereas the the selection of which exons
gets flexed in and out is really about
splicing factors driving this and
there's a separate process that controls
which polyviolation side is selected at
the three prime end right so this nicely
breaks this out into three different
components of that transcript
so that we can sum up these transcripts
if necessary and compare them and ask
questions well okay so if we see a lot
of diverse in the gene is it at a five
Prime man is it either three primate or
what not
so
um Downstream of Cerberus we're using
packages such as Swan to do this
analysis so I thought I would show you
this one for the swan plot output for
one transcription factor which is math2c
now uh this is math2c and uh I'm showing
you the major isoform plotted as a
percentage here
um across a set of satellites and the
first thing that should Stand Out is
that actually depending on which cell
line you're in there's a different major
isoform
okay
um
the other thing that that you should
notice and here is that actually one of
these major isoforms is missing a good
chunk of the three prime end which turns
out to have the trans activation domain
and so certainly this particular isoform
would be predicted to do something very
different
from the other isoforms that reached the
the typical three prime end
the third thing is that in with this
triplet annotation it's pretty clear
that uh all of these isoforms share the
same TSS it's number one so the
annotated TSS in the main select is
actually the TSS that's used here
but now we can based on looking at the
other triplet numbers see which ones
share the same intran chains I'm sorry
that it's cutting off on the side here
so the purple means they're sharing the
same intron chain
and the these guys that have the the
orange arrows are sharing the same three
prime end okay the same PES
okay
so
um
for me at least this really solves the
problem of very quickly seeing where
some of these differences are
now returning to the the full data set
that we have
we are detecting 65 of the genes that
would be predicted to be detected based
on the fact that they should have a poly
a Gene uh poly a uh coordination but
this actually really differs based on
actually what the underlying biotype is
so it detects something like 93.7
percent of protein coding genes so for
most protein component genes we detect
them for about half of the protein
coding genes we detect them at the level
of 100 TPM in at least one sample which
gives us good confidence that actually
for those we are going to see multiple
isoforms and be able to reliably say
what the matrixo form is
this number drops down for link rnas but
we're still detecting most of link rnas
and actually you know we're not
detecting pseudo genes maybe we're
detecting too many to the genes I don't
know but
um some of these Solutions are obviously
transcribed so so that's there okay
now we're detecting something like 200
000 transcripts
of which 60 are known transcripts and uh
these other categories we have 12
percent of our rescues 21 which are
another in catalogs and six percent that
seem to have a new axon all together
now how many isoforms are we detecting
per Gene there's lots of ways to look at
that here's one
um I guess you guys maybe don't spend a
lot of time think about how many
isoforms there are for particular chains
but for example there's one gene map K10
that has 192 isoforms in gen code
and we detect about 97 isoforms in our
data set
uh by contrast there's a one gene
elastin which has 35 isoforms in gen
code but we detect 286 in encode in fact
we detect something like 250 of them in
one cell line which is cover size
in that particular cell line it's
expressed as something like 10 000 TPMS
and it's just making a huge number of
isoforms it's beautiful
uh but there are others where we pick a
lot less
sure so so that plot to me is not very
meaningful
uh but I had a discussion one day with
uh liar who's also in the audience and
uh when I told him about my triplet idea
he suggested well why don't you try to
plot it as a simplex
and so the idea there
is that we we can essentially convert
these numbers that we have here for the
different genes
into a a coordinate that where you can
add each of the three coordinates and
add up to one and if you can do that
then you can plot it inside of its
triangle
now if you have a simple Gene that which
is just one isoform that is going to end
up dead in the center of this particular
triangle but the more you go towards one
of the three corners the more you're
going to be doing one form of splicing
and so the forms here are going to be
that if you go in this blue corner and
towards the here you're doing more five
Prime and selection
if you're going more towards this corner
you're doing more three prime end
alternate splicing and here it would be
more internal splicing
and so now we can look at these
different genes each gene across each
data set
and see where they go here
uh well it's a little washed out from my
angle but I hope it looks okay for you
guys
um and so for example for that Gene the
last thing that I was telling you about
you can see actually that a lot of these
samples are really doing internal
splicing so that the ends are actually
staying the same it's just a combination
of exons that you're using they're
changing whereas math to see is actually
either near the center or it's going
towards the Tes and if you remember we
are always using the same TSS for that
particular Gene so the the actual ratio
that you're going to have is going to be
something about the internal splicing
versus three prime end choice
and we can go look at this for any Gene
there are genes where we can see
actually a lot of isoforms that we
detect but if we actually limit
ourselves to 90 of the thank you ninety
percent of the express genes if we limit
ourselves to isoforms.com for 90 of the
expression
that all of a sudden their behavior
changes so for example there's lots of
lots of minor types of forms minorized
for himself called 3a1 that seem to be
about internal exons
but the moment that you take just the
isoforms are about
accounting for 90 of the expression you
either end up dead in the Middle with
one isoform or you have a little bit of
difference at the 3.9
okay
so I'll tell you in a minute about uh
what this looks like globally but first
I can now actually uh answer a question
that I know has been burning in all of
your minds which is
how often is that main select isoform
the major isoform
okay
and the short answer is it depends on
whether you're looking at it as do we
detect it at all in a sample or do we
never detect it right or do we only we
we see a switch and the short answer is
that for tsses actually the main select
is pretty good
in fact
um I don't have it on a plot I have it
on another plot if you are interested
but but the difference is that we see
are primarily not going to be at the
tsses uh but the differences that we see
are going to be really when you combine
all three of them together the TSS the
intron chain and the three prime and
together the proportion of them where we
for example never detect the triplet as
a major isoform right
uh is it's going to be 32 so 1 minus 68.
um
and this particular plot gives you the
sense that there are some genes that are
where you're always using the main
select and there are some genes like
math2 where you're never using actually
the main select that's your major
isoform okay
all right so going back now to looking
at all genes globally where do they fall
if you plotted all the genes on this
simplex
well
um a lot of them fall still inside of
this middle region where they're either
dead in the center or they're in this
mixed region but now we have these genes
that end up in these three corners that
are labeled as flexing
PSS and PES
this is for Gen code this is just taking
the general annotations and doing this
analysis and this is doing it with the
observed isoforms that we have
and I hope that you can see that
actually the proportion of genes that
we're reporting as having differences at
the TSS go up as we'll do the
professional genes that we label as
having t e s but also the proportion of
ones that we label as internal splicing
so all of them actually are increased
compared to the 10 code 340 equivalent
the the last part
um
that we can now do is I mentioned that
in gen in encode we have both human and
mouse samples right so we can actually
ask the question
of
um how often do we see the same thing
for the same gene across the two
different genomes
right
when we look actually across match
tissue samples in the two species we
start seeing that there are genes I'll
start at the bottom that seem to have
similar Behavior like for example called
an A1 in human and mouse is really
behaving the same way but we have other
genes such as ctcf
that in in human
seem to have a free sorry TSS Choice as
the primary thing driving
uh their isoform
uh diversity whereas that is not the
case in the mouse data
and if you go look at gen code for those
two you'll see that that's also
reflected by Genco so there are genes
very interesting genes that seem to have
different behaviors in human and mouse
at the level of splicing diversity in
fact uh it's only about 40 of the genes
that end up in the same sector of this
triangle in both species
so in summary
um I told you about this data set from
encode that we're in the process for
analyzing it we've developed these tools
such as lapa to correct the flat frame
and the three prime lens of the isoforms
and this is being done to produce this
Consolidated gtf of all of the
longweight IRC data that we've analyzed
uh we use Swan to to look at alternate
splicing between the different action
forms for specific genes or across data
sets but really it's Cerberus that's
doing the heavy lifting for us by using
this triplet annotation I told you about
to really get to what kind of diversity
we're dealing with
and I told you about the fact that
um the for the majority
um of the genes with more than two
isoform the main select is not the major
isoform detector
and that there are distinct changes uh
in this isoform diversity for the same
genes in human and Mass
now uh I have a huge number of people
that I need to thank
um a lot of the work that I told you
today was really done by by a real
bright guy bradiston Fairley Reese along
with the new graduates of lion of sun
who've been working together on this
data and then there's a lot of other
work that I didn't have time to tell you
about on the mouse side and what's done
by Liz and nargus
and this was all done in collaboration
with my uh partner in crime Barbara Walt
at Caltech along with Brian and Diane
and also um wanted to thank liar for
suggesting the the Simplex approach for
plotting all of this
and uh thank you to all my funding
sources
thank you
[Applause]
I'm back to you and Alejandro had the
first question
hey thank you great joke uh just maybe I
miss this how do you know that this is
not that you're not seeing the Decay
like the transitional decay of the
biggest isoform and that's why you see
this intermediate isoform that
where we are not established and won't
be really processed into proteins maybe
I missed that and then a bit related to
that is whether have you explore RNA
binding proteins could those also be
affecting how these other isoforms are
established or like they Prevail somehow
okay yeah yeah so so I I I think that
all the RNA that we're looking at is
pretty much the steady state as measured
from these bolt measurements in the
tissue
uh now
RNA that's in the process of degrading
doesn't really have a long Lifetime and
so I I don't know how much of it we
would see right now one of the things
that we're doing to convince ourselves
that these are full length is we're
making sure that we see both the poly
and and the TSL
and so if we if we don't see both we
don't consider a full length three that
doesn't go in the analysis this doesn't
mean that you couldn't have the TSO go
with the degraded RNA
but it makes it less likely and and so
that was why I said with lapa we want to
see multiple ends and in the same Peak
region at the five Prime men before we
think that that's really going to be a a
real RNA that we want to bank on if we
only saw it or read once or twice and at
a particular spot we that would not be
enough for us to call it as an ISO phone
foreign
yeah that was amazing now I understand
why you're doing these Simplex so why
does the simplest has like kind of
streak structure uh the streak structure
even the lines on this yeah exactly no
the the when you go to all genes oh for
all genes oh this is probably due to um
sorry yeah that one right here yeah this
is probably due to actually what those
ratios work out to be right uh but but
really uh there's a huge amount of
isoforms that are just sitting that
Center here okay 8 000 of them sitting
here
um and uh and there's relatively few of
these things here so yeah
the scaling that makes it look like
there's just only a few here yeah I'll
ask you later the more biological
question have you looked at the isoforms
that change like a protein sequence like
what's the fraction of that wow you know
our our our our friends at nhdri keep on
wanting this in in three dimensions so
that it's like a pyramid a pyramid
protein
the third dimension that's what happened
yeah we're working on it
great we're gonna take one more question
while Anna sets up Murphy
um so thank you for an excellent talk
and uh with respect to the Simplex
representation and you showing you know
some genes are more similar to each
other than others is there um a distance
measure or some
you know measure you could kind of rank
jeans and start thinking about how close
or far they are from each other in this
context yeah I I I I would love to come
up with one I haven't thought it's true
enough but but you could imagine in our
case we just simply divided this into
four four sections right
um
but you're right we should be able to go
through some sort of Delta on this
Simplex beside us and particular it
might be useful for the human Mouse
comparisons to really quantify that so
so thank you
all right okay let's think are they one
more time